responsibility for themselves in that
respect like that 100 agree because then
it's like if you knew he was a bad guy
and you still went there then it's just
like you knew the outcome like let's
like let's be like get like saying like
having a baby with Nick Cannon not to
like distance but like you know your
child is not gonna get special special
attention and so I was like I can feel
your pain but at the same time kind of
useful is it really yeah it's like
chicken it takes two to make a baby but
yeah if you could see the red flags try
and avoid it but
so why don't why do you not like blaming
women when it is our fault because I
think at the same time like when
emotions come into things it can like
blind your logic so some women like it's
like when people stay in abusive
relationships it's like someone who's
never been in that situation can of
course be like why don't you just leave
why don't you just leave but it's like
you're so emotionally that's why I think
therapy is good but then I know a lot of
people can afford therapy or don't
actually know
what's going on yeah so it can get a bit
see I I still think if you're an abusive
relationship it's your fault I don't
think you deserve it which is different
like I don't think it's like I don't
think it's not your fault if he hits you
but it's your fault if you stay yeah
because a lot of times those girls will
like go back like keep going back to him
and it's just like yeah that that is the
question and then and then on top of it
you make a child with him it's the it's
the emotional manipulation or like
sometimes Financial it's literally you
know I think it is stupidity stupidity I
don't know genuinely I think it's stupid
because I actually know someone that did
that just for the sake of staying with
the guy she had a whole baby and
everyone that really genuinely cared
about her was like listen leave open
your eyes like do the right thing some
people don't want to be saved but I
don't I don't think it's like like I
feel like sometimes we use these words
to take accountability off of women like
emotional manipulation it's like you're
kind of putting it back on him when it's
your choice it is but like because if
you don't if you're not like emotionally
mature then you don't like yours whose
fault is it if you're not emotionally
mature
yeah I guess I guess I guess okay it's
like it's kind of like you're talking
like we're kids We're Not Kids yeah a
tree if you're like I do feel like a bit
like yeah the self-responsibility part
does need to come into account sometimes
and it's like if you'll see again if
you'll see in the morning size and
you're still it's like saying this fire
is hot yeah it's still going in there
it's like so even though this is like
mean or it sounds mean right it's hard I
should say harsh is a harsh reality but
isn't it better that she knows the
reality so she can make decisions
accordingly reality is always best I
think reality gives people a better
understanding of how they should
maneuver in life and especially like I
know everyone says like sugar shoot your
shot but it's like I know I couldn't go
up to like Justin Bieber
because I'm just like I don't know like
you've never met me I'm not like I've
not been in your Social Circle so it's
like kind of be real or even like level
up so that you're within those circles I
think it's better to like level yourself
up and be able to like match that high
aspect person that you're trying to get
rather than just be like wait Give Me
Everything wait hold on say that again
I'm sorry so I'm saying like it's better
to kind of try and level how do you
level yourself up in a sense of like
social Circle wise money-wise
business-wise like moving up the ranks
so it's not like weird like where's this
woman come from and it's like you're not
do you think men care about your money
yeah
I don't think they care as much as women
do I don't know I don't know do you
think men care about your Social Circle
and your status set like clout clout
chasing guys do is that typically the
men that women want no so I didn't so
it's like if you're gonna level up how
would you do that for men
I have I have failed what makes you
think about it yeah because I don't like
them because what do men really want not
these nails I'm so sorry nervous
from me
they typically want Purity youth Purity
they don't want a girl that's banged the
whole football team okay but I didn't
say you did I wasn't talking about you I
have I have not they they preferably
want a girl with under
um 10 bodies they don't want to grow
this club with more than 10 typically
ideal would be under seven from what
I've interviewed guys
um so you're actually you know your
chances of having a happy marriage is
um it depends on how many partners
you've had so if you've only had one
partner you have an 80 chance of being a
happily married in 10 in 10 years if
you've had two it drops down to 50 if
you get over five it gets around 20 what
relationships five sexual partners so if
you've had sex with over Five Guys your
chance of having a happy marriage in 10
years is twenty percent how did they
study that
um they would ask people how many sexual
partners they had and then in 10 years
they would ask if they're happy or
they're still married wow
so it's it's a pretty like clear
correlation the more Partners you've had
the less likely you are to stay
marriages just seem so upsetting
nowadays we don't see anyone like Jaden
will we were like clinging on and then
all their stuff came up and it was like
it's because of women women are the
problem in most marriages
not all but most we leave who who's
whose fault is it the quitter or the
person that stays
oh it's like it's a joint thing it's a
joint right but if me and you make an
agreement right we say hey we're going
to be together for life okay and you
leave and I say whose fault is it I
guess I'll if I'm not abusive if I'm not
abute because that's all the first thing
is like girls would be like oh men are
abusive and cheaters okay let's take
those off the tables
if it's neither of those thing things
and I stay and you quit whose fault is
it
what is so there's so much new ones to
it because everyone's like because it's
like especially like you know have you
heard the thing of like um
like oh what's the thing when it's like
men purposely don't do house chores
because they know the woman's gonna do
it do women purposely fix things around
the house and mow the lawn
because women will always whine about
doing house chores but they don't talk
about men usually fix things around the
house mow the lawn what if they don't do
that stuff then they're just like Sons
like grown sons basically you know what
I mean like men if men are grown son
husbands it's the fault of women because
what would you agree with the statement
men will do anything to get laid yes so
if women are accepting grown son's son
husbands whose fault is that yeah it
makes it kind of peak for the rest of us
because then it's like if you have a
certain standard then you're high
maintenance but it's like no this is
just but I feel like also
um as much as the woman you know because
we what if the woman tries to change the
sun husbands and you know tries to you
know better them but then they still
have a choice uh yeah like why are you
trying to change Madness that usually
productive now you know that you know
they're like I can change him
is that typically a good strategy to get
you may be a good looking guy that
doesn't do much is it a good strategy to
try to change him no but maybe like
highlighting a few things would give
them a better viewpoint on what to work
on
you can't just go around being a dick
okay do you do you have women friends
that are lazy that are just bums you
know what I mean did they ever magically
one day not become a bum no have they
always have they gotten better or worse
over time
or the same I don't have to be mobile I
used to be a bum
yeah I used to be a complete but my name
used to clean and I used to do anything
but as where does it may sound I had
like a spiritual awakening and that
opened my eye to more things and was it
because of someone else or because of
you because of me so is it smart to go
after guys that are bums
oh my gosh yeah that's why I think the
whole state of society is women's fault
yeah
[Music]
I think everything's women's fault
you're a woman yeah yeah she's like yeah
but I'm smart
I I think um we can look at things as at
a society level and not necessarily an
individual level right I'm not saying
well your relationships and your lives
are your own fault personally just like
mine mine as well right but as a society
again men will do anything to get laid
yeah it's kind of scary if they act a
certain way it's the fault of women and
I've also interviewed men they they act
like bad guys because we prefer them
when we're younger yeah and so whose
fault is it if the men act bad if we're
picking the bad men it's a t i feel like
it's a two-sided thing because like
women have fiend and intermencing by the
men feed into women so it's just like
this
who started it
who is in control of sex men or women
women a thousand percent yes but so so
who started it
but sometimes but I would say sometimes
like the way men come towards women it
can be like a lot of women would just be
like Oh I'm just gonna do it
yeah because a lot of women don't even
half the time so so whose choice is that
assuming there's no assault right
assuming there's none of that whose
fault
I feel like we already know how they
would react
we already know their intentions like
the way they would talk to us what what
they would do for us so for us to react
to certain ways it's it's really and
truly like up to us to
spread them cheeks or not but now that
women have a like standards like they
even have you seen all the videos on
Tick Tock like as soon as you start to
understand for yourself the amount of
men is like I'll tell you oh I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why it's because
you're no longer as valuable as you were
before
in what sense so again what amend value
Purity youth looks main main three
things roughly I mean there's
rough overview right like what what did
every King have
hot young virgins
you know like and so so what girls will
do is they'll have sex with all the bad
guys they'll have sex with like 10 15
bad guys whatever it is and then they'll
ask for the same price as they demanded
at when they were 10 years younger and a
virgin
and now they have less options because
the guys don't want to pay that much
you're a used car and use oh no you've
got but don't you think you should just
like be able to have fun in your younger
years
um it depends what outcomes you want
like if you're just like exploring no
I'm saying like what like do you want to
be married with kids or do you want to
be by yourself or do you want to be with
a woman
so if you want to be married with kids
is it is it good to have a lot of exes
that you've slept with is that good for
a marriage I mean what about the like to
contradict that a little bit it's like
when men be like oh I want a free girl
but then you can't be a freak without
having a slip because then if you're
pure then your might be classed as like
boring what do they want the freak girl
for
do men typically wife freak girls
typically
no I don't really
so so they do want the it's it's not sad
because it's based on choices there's no
problem if you want to Market yourself
yeah if you want to Market yourself as
the freak girl and that's the type of
men you want to attract that's fine
you'll probably get access to higher
value men than the normal girl if that's
your mating strategy you want to just
give it up and see if you can get one of
them to stay that's a strategy okay try
it but do you think
do you think you can blame a woman if
she doesn't like know any better
um I it's not about blame it's about
outcomes you know what I mean it's like
you could say I was young but that
doesn't take away the fact that you
slept with 20 dudes yeah you know you
could say we could have some empathy and
understanding but it doesn't change the
outcome of the situation which is men
are gonna look at you different if
you've done certain things and they find
out now most girls will lie and some
girls get away with it but you can't lie
to yourself like girls talk too much
they'll slip up about it
I mean five men yeah I think girls are
aware of that but it's like the same way
of like a guy slept with burgers and
whatever what if a woman like I was like
I want my future husband to only have
slept with three women that's going to
be like do you think do you think that's
common
no do you think it's common for women to
want that from Men
maybe do you think that women are that
want to sleep with say Drake or worried
about his body count no no
anything of men
um that if they were gonna date Amber
Rose they would be worried about her
past
no but these are publicly
you don't think
high value man that's like making six
figures he's got his own business would
be worried about Amber Rose's reputation
dating her
no probably not but she's beats the
whole brand around sex
you think there's a chef like slow on
her foot yeah I'm saying you don't think
there's she's like you don't think he
would have any qualms about having her
as a mother of his kids
that would be tough for a wife
maybe but she has kids which is which is
that's that's the strategy the hor the
Horus kind of use as they get they get
the kid off of the guy that makes a lot
of money and they don't want to be a
wife they just want to be side chick
that's fine I mean do that fine we've
had side chicks for all of history I
feel like that's why she goes for Like
Rappers and yeah she's trying to get the
good she's she even said it herself yeah
she did I think no because I just decide
chicken life I don't know I would I
would just always like want more for
yourself type Vibe like it's just kind
of I mean if that's what you want to do
but you can you can want more but can
you get it and at this point is she
gonna get a guy that's making good money
and is successful that wants to take her
seriously that does all the low maybe as
a side chick right she's not going to be
the main as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible